So the world is becoming more and more mobile,
and so the expectation is that the sorts of things we do with big GPU's today--
maybe one day we'll see being done with something you carry in your pocket,
so where do you see GPU computing having an impact on sort of the mobile world?
&gt;&gt; Well like I said, computing is just sort of everywhere,
and it's certainly coming to the mobile space.
I think cell phones today are replacing our laptop PCs,
and there are opportunities, and there are new mobile devices.
It's something that is always on, we're carrying it with us,
we're interacting with people and friends, as well as ourselves with the device,
and that's another opportunity for computing to make a difference.
Camera is one area,
and one thing you do see is that cell phones are starting to take over the digital camera market,
and there are things that you can do with a digital camera, with a processor, with an interactive test screen--
things like computational photography and computer vision with the camera
that just wants to be done on the device and really changes it from a point-and-shoot thing
to a more dynamic interface to something interactive,
and I hope to see some really cool stuff happen there.